hello everyone its Alicia Malone from
movieclips I'm here at South by
Southwest Film Festival hanging with the
wonderful Michael Shannon how you doing
good we're in one of the karaoke rooms
at the highball which is part of the
Alamo Drafthouse my favorite cinema in
the world
I was so looking forward to Midnight
Special I kept talking about it not only
one of my most anticipated movies here
but of the whole year because I'm kind
of a die-hard Jeff Nichols fan all right
you've worked with him now four times
does it feel like a different experience
each time yeah it's interesting I mean
every film he makes he seems to set the
bar a little higher he seems to have him
a little bigger budget a little broader
scope he's very good at challenging
himself you know pushing himself
watching Midnight Special is so
engrossing the whole time it just kept
revealing more and more what was it like
for you getting the script did it feel
that way as you turned the page first
time Jeff ever brought up midnight
special to me he merely referred to it
as a chase movie he said I want to shoot
this movie with you driving around in a
badass car and most of its at night and
it's called The Midnight Special
that was it I said well okay that sounds
fun and Jaden
I mean he's really impressive yes and
there's something so incredible when
you're watching a film kind of
unsettling with it when a kid knows a
lot and maybe knows more than the adults
involved and he brought that
intelligence were you impressed with him
oh yeah I mean that's hard to find you
know Jeff saw a lot of kids for that
part he knew it was gonna be a huge
challenge to find a kid that you really
believed because it requires a certain
wisdom and depth and I'm trying to be so
careful when I talk about the film not
to spoil anything I appreciate how much
do you want to keep things secret for an
audience very much very much yeah you
know based on the few people I've talked
to that I've seen it the less you know
going into it it seems to be
the more that you get out of it I know
why I'm here